we're now at the most important part of
the conversation
which is uh bitcoin um i wanna caveat
this entire part of the conversation
with uh
you manage uh by proxy a lot of money
uh about 150 billion in assets uh
maybe just talk a little bit about uh
first
what work you guys have done on bitcoin
have you looked at it what some of the
structural issues are
with if you actually did want to go get
exposure to it
and then we can kind of talk through um
just kind of how you guys
look at an asset that is in you know the
finance markets very new
uh very different kind of just your
thought process and the work you guys
have done
uh around bitcoin specifically sure well
i
i'm just going to kind of jump in here
and again you you guide me wherever
um you'd like to take it i don't want to
get too far into the technical weeds on
this but i'll give you my 30 000 foot
kind of stratus
strategist view we really started paying
attention
to what was happening in the crypto
world back in 2017
and then really after that massive uh
rally
in terms of pricing and the crash you
know
the the idea that it just didn't go away
right that it didn't just vaporize
itself after that
crash um from an all-time high it really
has been on the radar ever since then
trying to get an understanding of what
is going on here
and what is the potential path forward
i'll give you some thoughts about how we
think about it
today again from an asset allocation
standpoint and from a strategy
point of view so we think about
cryptocurrencies
as effectively a digital currency but
the challenge with that from our
perspective
is that we don't trade currencies that
is not really
an asset class in our view it's not that
we don't have
hedged exposures to currency so a good
example of this is we
we found an active manager a third-party
strategy that invests in global
infrastructure
and part of their thesis is hedging
around
some currency exposures depending on the
country
and so it was just the right exposure
that we were looking for
and even though the hedging part of it
is really not something
that is in keeping with how we think
about the world
um we've offloaded that to them to do so
if that if they think they can add value
there or at least provide ballast in a
hedging currency
approach we're okay but with pursuing
that strategy so that's point one
the other aspect of this is if we really
wanted to
express a very nuanced view so
without a currency you know as a uh
primarily us-based investor if we
thought
a currency in a particular region or
country was going to go against us but
we really thought there was an
attractive investment opportunity there
we might think about putting a tactical
allocation in place
with a hedging component to it but in
general we are not
active currency traders and i think to
do this
right and to do this efficiently and
have any shot at adding value
you really do have to be very active in
terms of trading so that's kind of
key point one the other point of it is
if you think about
cryptocurrency as more of a store of
value
then we would equate that as being more
like digital gold
um and at the end of the day why would
you own
gold it's really for inflation
hedging purposes and so at the end of
the day based on
our analysis we actually think the
better inflation hedge over
longer horizons is equities and in
particular
dividend paying equity so not the high
yielders but those that have that
ability to grow dividends over time and
so
it's not quite the right fit at the
moment
depending on how you define it in terms
of our asset class universe and so that
has been
a little bit of a challenge in terms of
thinking about
how it fits into a portfolio and what
its role might actually
be i know you talked to kramer not that
long ago
about having well why don't you just
throw one percent
allocation into a portfolio no big deal
right one percent
but if you think about the size of our
asset base
you know we're somewhere in the neighbor
of 150 billion dollars in assets under
management
so that moves around as the market moves
around
but we effectively become bitcoin whales
if we took
one percent of that uh asset base
and plunked it into uh crypto currencies
of sorts and you know bitcoin i think
the market cap there
would equate to somewhere in the
neighborhood of the size of a stock like
at
t so it would effectively be saying
let's make an allocation to one security
let's buy one percent um in every single
client's portfolio at t even if we
thought the investment pieces made sense
and this is by the way not a knock on a
t at all this is just a hypothetical
example
it's just really too small at this stage
to try to incorporate it into a
portfolio
in an efficient way and then in a
meaningful way
one percent of anything doesn't really
move the needle
uh for better or worse and so we tend to
try to take larger positions and
portfolios
um whatever exposure we're trying to to
gain access to
than just kind of one percent so that's
that's sort of how we think about that
i think the area that's really
interesting and just fascinating to me
is the technology underpinning uh
cryptocurrency and it's really the
blockchain technology
i think if that led to some scalable
uses
we would absolutely pursue those
opportunities from an investment
standpoint but just
trading you know like defy tokens or
day-to-day trading you know bitcoin it
that's just really
it's not an area that you know we're
playing in from an asset allocation an
investment strategy standpoint i think
longer term i'm all in on the idea
so i'm a big fan i'm watching from afar
but i'm definitely
a big fan here i think it will continue
to gain traction
again as people start to come around to
the idea of
is it a usable currency is it a store of
value what what kind of role how do we
define it
where does it sit in a portfolio context
i know traders love it
today for its uncorrelated asset like
nature i'm all for uncorrelated assets
as well but again there's still some
some hurdles that we need to overcome
here and then
i think too you know it's still just a
very very new world
and and new asset and i think there is
some inherent distrust
like it or not there is a little bit of
a stigma to overcome there but i think
really the blockchain technology could
be the platform of innovation
for the future not only for like this
next cycle but the next
multiple cycles and if you think about
kind of pre-covered that long
slow sluggish cycle that we've been
through the last 11 plus years
there's been an innovation drought there
have been pockets of innovation but it
really hasn't been
grand and sweeping enough to drive
meaningful
productivity enhancements and gdp growth
and so
i think the prospects for this are just
really really
interesting uh so much potential here
but it's still
very very early day so we're going to
keep watching it very closely and
you know maybe i can come back on the
show and talk to you about when and
how we start to implement it in
portfolios
so uh one i think that everything uh
you just said is really really rational
right and i think that uh there's this
thought process
in uh the bitcoin slash crypto community
of uh everyone's asleep at the wheel no
one's paying attention like
you know the large asset management
firms are completely missing this and
uh just given the you know thoughts
you've shared here
uh obviously you guys have one been
paying attention
for multiple years to have a pretty good
understanding of the various narratives
around the asset
uh and then three even have gone as far
as like well even if we could get there
as to yes this asset
makes sense for whatever reason like
could we do it right
from an execution standpoint and
i think every single thing you outline
um not only is one rational but makes
sense and is challenges you guys face
my favorite question to ask people
though is what would change your mind
or what what are the things that you're
going to look for in the future in terms
of saying
you know what now maybe the time where
we think this becomes more interesting
is it
price related is it structure and like
regulation related
is it macro economy something shifts and
then
something like this becomes more
interesting and just how do you think
through
kind of maybe things you'll watch
as this unfolds um and really the
thought process is for those people that
are listening
uh you know they're probably more in
solar looking like they're looking at
bitcoin
not necessarily looking at here's the
things that major asset management firms
or
or asset allocators are looking at as
kind of um
you know warning signs or alarm bells or
whatever in terms of
bringing more attention to it yeah i
think it's just a few short things
really that i'm looking for but maybe
maybe it's asking way too much i mean i
think structure
is definitely important and
kind of getting an understanding of
maybe perhaps which
cryptocurrency is going to win out
there's so many different ones
um seeing a little bit of consolidation
there just like a better understanding
of what the landscape or the competitive
landscape is going to look like so i
think
i think structure is important um i
think
time just helps right this has only
really been on the scene for maybe 10 or
11 years
that maybe and so i think that you know
time and education and hand-holding
albeit virtual i think would definitely
help
a better understanding of use cases um
is also critical so if i think about you
know the us
today what are those use cases you know
it makes a ton of sense
in other countries where perhaps there's
a lot more distrust around
government power political power
regulatory oversight etc
totally get that and let me just say the
crisis of confidence that we
experienced at the beginning of this
year from
you know government policy officials
public health policy officials
even you know the fed i mean there was
so much mixed messaging going on like
who's in charge
and you know what is the path forward
going to look like and who makes the
final decision i mean i totally get it
that's maybe kind of a a weak example
but i
understand sort of the inherent distrust
and wanting to kind of step away from
you know the us dollar perhaps other
kind of global currencies and so
um i don't think that we're necessarily
expecting to see
greater regulation in this area would be
kind of at odds
right a little bit with uh the whole
idea
um of cryptocurrencies so that's not
necessarily it i think it's more on the
structure
of the industry side consolidation use
cases
and then really vehicles to implement
more on the innovation side
right not not just trading the
currencies themselves but
you know is there a venture capital fund
or are there multiple venture capital
funds or
private investment type of vehicles that
are capturing
early stage blockchain oriented
technologies
investments innovations that kind of
thing i think there's a huge
opportunity there there's just not a lot
to choose from
today and so again i think it comes back
to it's just still a little bit early
we need to see a little bit more growth
and expansion of
of the use cases and the opportunities
there and then i think asset managers
will start to come around
i think that is a very fair view of the
world uh and i do not envy
you having the conversation internally
about hey do you guys want to look at
this bitcoin thing
because i can only imagine the the
various reactions that you get
internally
there are a lot of different reactions
it's the wide spectrum
of uh emotions and opinions and feelings
about it absolutely but that's the
reason
why we're having the conversation right
if we were all thinking along the exact
same lines
something's wrong and so it is
definitely a lively
um and very recurring debate that
continues and
will continue